[Music]
you know how flemeth like to say
everybody knows everything
[Music]
it would be fine if the truth was it
nobody knows anything
Helen live in on them of that feels like
we've all been here forever
where's this just a little scratch
please don't kill that man know what I
will give you ten million dollars drop
my husband in the ocean for the Sharks
is right and wrong heaven in weird stuff
going on right now this old man's a part
of it but nobody knows it okay John you
want the juice you don't
it's funny huh where in the world are we
[Music]
my husband is joining me here the day
after tomorrow I told him that I would
charter a boat for fishing - nothing I
want you to take him out of your bum
don't let him get drunk then drop him in
the ocean for the Sharks in return I
will give you ten million dollars cash I
[Music]
leave a me you need the money we taking
not letting fish I'll take two you take
eight the Serenity needs an overhaul
my granddaughter needs money for the
next semester and why would I take you
out Duke you're bad luck
no no Constance told me the real reason
you fired me
pity is worse than a fist in the face
I'm not begging you big a deal I'm just
telling you when life offers you an
opportunity like this you have to take
it
[Music]
okay
but you stay close to me today do cami
it needs to deliver me from temptation
[Music]
my wife my beautiful wife she arranged
this trip she set up on the internet
night after night typing away to find
the perfect poet but to make this trip
perfect because she wants it to be
perfect perfect for me
now myself allowed to say some of the
ones of Buchan same as any other not fly
to some other Island but I don't got
time I only got two days so let's be
here at 7:00 just me you and the mother
tuna I already told you it's not worth
the risk
I'm not gonna do it please think about
it mr. dill okay honey every man has his
price tomorrow at 7:00 a.m. I'm gonna be
here so should you
you made it all the way up to the
counter before you decided to turn
around and see me why'd you come dill
how do you think that's just I heard you
went to the mercantile Bank this morning
who'd you get Carter
how did you do I've come so you know
damn well I did
found ya everybody knows everything well
I heard the bank refused to extend your
loan so now you can't even afford gas
I'm just a little hurt you got all the
way as far as Joe's place with when you
decided on the last resort
take her till I know more than a hooker
okay can't afford Oaks yeah come in and
talk to you it's 2:30 in the morning
you're out at sea mostly I keep missing
you by a bigger margin every time but
with the storm keeping you ashore I
thought I'd take my opportunity what I
have in my hands may change your life
and give you the one thing you've always
wanted that sounds great Reed that kind
of a big day tomorrow
yes mr. Dilton I know all about your big
day and I think you should hear what I
have to say here you like to say
everybody knows everything what if the
truth was nobody knows anything I got a
feeling today yesterday today's the day
I can feel it this time and I can feel
him
good to see you John it took so long to
find you what do you say say I'm not
gone Johnny or it's funny huh why would
you want to find me my husband has never
seen your face you were right about him
he's either with him out what's this
this is a scratch
Oh scratch huh I want you to take him
out on your boat and drop him in the
ocean for the Sharks
they say she came all the way to see you
yes she's about temptation it's right
and wrong in Plymouth everybody knows
everything
I'll get kind of a big day tomorrow I
know all about your big day like
everybody knows something kind of down
now you explain that deal will you have
yourself a good day now and do what's
right okay deliver me from temptation
are you going to take them out you're
not writing your mind
my wife says you're being a little
difficult
there's something wrong tell me what
this is all about
sometimes we do bad things for good
reasons
[Music]
you